MIT is rolling the dice on a new online
course this summer that teaches students
how to be better poker players the class
is called poker theory and analytics and
it is free to the public it emphasizes
careful strategy and data analysis to
get the best return on investment in a
given game MIT is no stranger to the
poker world remember the Kevin Spacey
movie 21 that was based on the
unofficial mit blackjack team that
gained notoriety for counting cards and
winning big at casinos in the 1990s the
class taught by a finance graduate
student by the name of Kevin Desmond
yeah this poker class he's actually
using poker as a lesson in risk analysis
and I was looking through the article
and his first lesson is that beginner
students need to play what's called
tight aggressive I know neither of us
are poker players so I didn't know what
that meant I had to look it up
it means betting and raising often but
rarely just calling other people's bets
Wow really apparently I don't know it's
not a poker player so like this is the
first lesson but there's a two part
focus you have to master the
fundamentals and you have to track
factors that other players aren't
tracking apparently that one of the
things that they say this course can
teach you and I guess aside from making
lots of money yeah
investment management and trading and
how this theory can be applied to that
and it would seem that in both walks of
life whether you were a card player or
you're an investment banker this applied
theory this knowledge of data is key to
whether or not you not to borrow a poker
phrase lose your shirt I don't know if
that's a technical poker phrase isn't it
say it seems like sabermetrics it seems
like what they use in in in sports now
particularly baseball where Billy Beane
did that out with the Oakland A's where
you're looking at the numbers and the
numbers don't lie yeah you're looking
for undervalued assets you know my only
gripe with that movie 21 by the way was
that they whitewashed the cast most of
the real-life players were
asian-american but they chose a white
British actor as the male lead yes they
did Wow